c'est
bon c'est bon il y a quelques mois je
rencontre cette femme Corine isnar banis
professeur de
[Musique]
médecine je lui confie mon expérience
malheureuse avec des soignants je lui
décris une relation de soin qui ne
fonctionne plus et je vais jusqu parler
de
maltraitance loin de me juger ou de me
condamner elle m'explique que c'est
précisément la raison pour laquelle elle
a créé en 2015 une formation réservée au
soignant je travaille avec des équipes
avec que je connais depuis très
longtemps sur plan clinique qui sont des
gens dont je sais que sont des gens
merveilleusement investis dans leur
métier et pour autant même avec ça je
les vois de temps en temps avoir des
attitudes
que j'aimerais pas avoir qu'il a à mon
égard ou à l'égard de mes
proches son diplôme universitaire
s'appelle méditation gestion du stress
et relation de soins il dure 6 mois je
comprends que ce duu est là pour leur
réapprendre l'empathie la compassion la
bienveillance et la demande est forte
des soignants se portent candidat par
dizaines de toute la France elle peut en
accueillir une quarantaine chaque année
c'est très important pour nous de savoir
si vous allez bien que c'est de ça dont
on va parler ce qu'on essaie de partager
dans cet enseignement c'est de
rediscuter ensemble de pourquoi on est
soignant qu'est-ce que c'est que la
relation de
soin et de comment on peut découvrir
utiliser pratiquer la méditation pleine
conscience pour à la fois être de
meilleurs soignants et en même temps se
protéger entre guillemets de tout ce à
quoi on est exposé en tant que
soignant retisser un lien patient
soignant remettre du sens dans sa
pratique il existe une dizaine de
formation de ce genre en France celle de
Corine a la particularité de passer par
la méditation de pleine conscience
elle accepte de m'en ouvrir les portes
viendez
Rebecca j'ai été au côté de ma mère
pendant plusieurs années puisqu'elle a
eu un parcours de soins très compliqué
jusqu'à son déessas il y a quelques mois
et en allant au rendez-vous avec elle en
l'entendant en l'écoutant euh j'ai été
confronté à des choses qui me
paraissaient paradoxales euh ma mère me
racontait des moments avec des chefs de
service où elle euh bah elle pleurait
avant elle pleurait après parce que on
lui avait un peu mal parl qu'on avait
été froid qu'on avait mal communiqué
avec elle ou pas communiqué ou annoncé
des choses très brutales avec assez peu
de d'empathie et de bienveillance et je
comprenais pas le soin c'est pas juste
une ordonnance ou un examen une IRM le
soin c'est un tout enfin à mes yeux en
tout cas comment des gens qui ont choisi
comme parcours de vie comme comme Chem
professionnel le soin l'être au soin
peuvent-ils devenir un peu dur parfois
peu compatissant parfois malveillant et
j'irais même jusqu'à dire parfois
maltraitant maltraitant j'ai lâché le
mot je crains d'avoir jeté un
froid et puis non je me sens par moment
mauvais médecin ou pas par rapport à mes
compétences mais dans le relationnel oui
je sont pas bon médecin à l'heure
actuelle et j'espère que ça va
changer je n'ai pas le temps de
m'occuper comme je voudrais comme je
pense que la la relation serait la la
meilleure c'est un exemple tout simple
quand vous avez un un patient de 90 ans
que vous avez 15 minutes à lui accorder
vous avez déjà 30 minutes de retard et
que rien que le fait lui de se lever de
la salle d'attente d'aller dans votre
cabinet de se déshabiller de se
réhabiller vous avez déjà déjà 10 15
minutes de découler j'ai je vais trop
vite
euh j'ai peur de faire des erreurs ouais
il risque de passer à côté de quelque
chose de passer à côté de quelque chose
de potentiellement grave tu es pas tu es
pas un mauvais médecin c'est c'est le
fait que tu es tu tu as ta formation tu
as le contexte et tu fais en fonction du
contexte alors c'est vrai que si ça
pouvait être un outil de prévention la
méditation là pour pour prévenir
justement cette cette pensée qui l' a
parce que c'est c'est une pensée he une
pensée je suis un mauvais médecin ce
n'est qu'une pensée repositionner les
choses dans le contont texte dans ton
contexte aujourd'hui du boulot tu peux
pas faire autrement c'est pas de ta
faute pas biser puis tes émotions bah
voilà c'est c'est pas
to c'est moi qui vais beaucoup vous
accompagner pour un peu le coaching des
mémoires manifestement c'est un truc qui
vous stresse toujours beaucoup bien sûr
ça nous sert à valider en gros l'année
mais surtout c'est un moment d'échange
vous allez pouvoir partager votre vision
de du sujet que vous serez approprié et
donc vous allez voir queil y a aucune
raison d'être stressé pour les
mémoires quand je dis à mes à mes chefs
à l'hôpital que je dis que je vaisis
faire un diplôme universitaire ils me
disent très bien et quand je leur dis
que c'est de la pleine conscience ils
sont toujours un petit peu étonné et je
le CR pas sur les to je fais un
méditation ou pourquoi tu as honte j'ai
pas honte mais je suis pas sûre que tout
le monde
comprenne quand on parle de méditation
quand vous je sais pas si vous avez dit
à vos proches que vous alliez faire un
Dhu de méditation assez souvent ou en
tout cas nous on avait assez souvent ça
les gens tout à coup se mettaient à
faire ah oui
oh ça veut dire que le dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de personne encore la la
méditation est associée à quelque chose
d'exotique quelque chose d'oriental
associé aux aines à des monastère et
l'enjeu de de la méditation tel que nous
la transmettons à nos patients c'est le
même comment faire pour que dans la vie
qui est la mienne et bien il me soit
possible à certains moments de faire
preuve d'apaisement de discernement pour
mieux traverser tout ce qui voilà tout
ce qui compose mon
[Musique]
quotidien notre poitrine et notre ventre
s'élève et s'abaisse à leur
rythme la conscience du
mouvement de
l'air dans notre nez dans notre
gorge à chaque inspiration à chaque
expiration
[Musique]
c'était très dense
aujourd'huias quel âge
Nicolas
oui quand arrives tu
prénom c'est le
défi déjà c'est
pas vous prenez des
entrées moi je veux bien moi je veux
bien ce billet de sélection c'est qu'on
pense qu'il est dans sa maladie or il
est pas dans sa maladie il est une
personne qui a contracté une maladie
c'est pas la même chose qu' est pas ça
malad exactement et ben c'est justement
le problème c'est que les soignants
n'ont même pas le temps d'être dans
cette écoute active de comprendre le
patient et de et de l'accompagner dans
son dans sa réelle histoire ils sont
dans l'accompagnement de sa pathologie
ses effets secondaires ce qu'il faut
mettre en place pour l'accompagner au
mieux en terme de d'aide à domicile et
on s'arrête là et les
neme ilore enc deé moi je vois là déjà
un patient qui a un cancer tu t'occupes
quand il a un cancer dès qu'on dit que
tu es en rémission bah ciao va voir les
association débrouille-toi à l'extérieur
et VI avec ton ébé d'amocè on te revoit
dans 3 mois l'hôpital
public n'a pas les moyens en
faitéri qu'est-ce qu'on va faire chacun
d'entre nous pour l'hôpital au sens
grand
H ça je ne sais pas mais par contre on
peut faire c'est pour nous et cette
formation elle est là pour moi en fait
pour me permettre de me sentir bien avec
moi-même et aujourd'hui ça va de mieux
en mieux avec moi-même je suis prête à
apprendre pour pour aider les autres
enfin ça fait longtemps que je fais mais
mais de façon plus juste en fait en tout
cas qui correspond à mes valeurs parce
qu'il t'est arrivé de sentir que tu
étais pas complètement juste dans l'être
au soins avec les autres ou des fois
j'ai envie de les exploser hein quand
même donc il y a des fois on se
reconnaît pas quoi ah oui c'est ça fait
et c'est là et c'est là on se dit mais
ça va pas quoi c'est on est on n'est pas
maltraitant mais on n'est pas correct et
quand on n pas correct c'est qu'il y a
un problème c'est pas la personne qui en
face de nous qui est pas qui va pass che
nous qui allons pas
bien beaucoup de gens viennent dans ces
formations continues professionnelles
alors qu'ils ont beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle à un moment donné de
leur parcours où ils ont besoin de euh
rebattre les cartes de c'est quoi en
fait la relation de soin ils ont perdu
le sens de leur
métier ouis bonjour ça va ouais super
remis de la soirée vous avez pas fini
trop tard non non on est parti ver
garderett de
soleil
fatiguéard euh parmi vous tous est-ce
qu'il y en a donc infirmier ou
infirmière ouais des médecins voilà
beaucoup après j'ai oublié sûrement des
professions êre soignant psychologue
psychologue donc le thème le premier
thème c'est méditation émotion donc on
va méditer on va commencer à
méditer d'une façon qui nous permet
d'être en relation avec nos émotions et
donc vous pouvez fermer les yeux et puis
on essaie d'avoir une posture avec le
dos qui est
droite
si vous avez des talons vous pouvez
retirer vos chaussures comme ça vous
avez pied bien entrer dans le
sol j'ai essayé de former les soignants
mais il y a des résistances voilà je
vois bien il y a des
il y a du personnel soignant en
souffrance mais qui bah il faut pas
ouvrir la botte de Pandor quoi parce que
si on commence à regarder on va
s'effondrer si on commence à voir qu'on
va mal bah on est censé être celui qui
va bien et qui a de les autres donc
c'est pas simple hein il y a une
infirmière qui m'a dit non mais moi 30
ans que je suis en psychiatrie je me
suis jamais posé la question de mes
émotions enfin si j'avais des émotions
enfin comprenait elle m'a dit c'est
dingue quoi et depuis que je m'occupe de
mes émotions ben j'essaie de prendre
soin de moi une infirmière qui est dans
le dévouement et le sacrifice en
permanence en psychiatrie une infirmière
de secteur génial et ben pour la
première fois commence à s'intéresser à
se poser les questions de ses
besoins moi j'essaie d'amener une
curiosité pour les émotions les ses
propres émotions pour les soignants
eux-mêm et pour celles des autres et
peut-être des grilles de lecture qui
permettent de euh d'avoir moins peur
finalement de la souffrance de sa propre
souffrance pour aller pouvoir la
regarder travailler dessus et d'avoir
moins peur de la souffrance des autres
et du coup d'avoir moins de rejet en
France on a quand même un problème avec
la vulnérabilité quelqu'un de vulnérable
fragile c'est quelqu'un qui est pas
compétent et donc tout ce qui est du
domaine des émotions de la tristesse et
de et puis des traumas et ben on met s
le tapis sauf que bah souvent les gens
sont maltraitants parce qu'ils ont pas
regardé les séquelles en eux de ce
qu'ils ont vécu le bonheur des soignants
c'est la clé pour qu'il puisse mieux
soigner ça c'est sûr mais c'est une
évidence c'est pas forc for évident pour
tout le monde même pour les soignants de
de faire le choix de la bienveillance en
fait il y a quelque chose de rassurant
dans une posture de retrait qui parfois
suffit à donner une impression qu'on n
pas empathique en fait donc il y a ça
quand même qui est les soignants sont
aussi là pour rassurer pour encadrer
pour montrer qu'ils savent et ça c'est
aussi important et parfois c'est un peu
confondu avec une posture de retrait ou
de distance euh qui qui peut être prise
pour un manque de d'empathie en fait
imaginez que vous êtes invité chez des
personnes que vous connaissez pas très
bien et l'un des si c'est un couple l'un
des deux vous remet un un plateau dans
les mains que tu peux amener ce plateau
dans le salon et sur le plateau sont
posés tous les des des verres en cristal
vous prenez le plateau il y a une petite
défaillance sur la poignée vous en
rendez pas compte tout de suite et
patatra tout se casse la figure et tous
les veres sont par terre cassés tout de
suite qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
physiquement quelles sont vos émotions
et toutes vos premières pensées je suis
vraiment trop nulle la gène ah de la
gêne ça c'est l'émotion hein euh B c'est
la
culpabilité moi je me suis demandé si il
y avait pas quelqu'un qui était blessé à
cause du verre et où était parti jusqu'ù
était parti ah est-ce qu'il y a pas
quelqu'un qui s'est blessé jusqu'où est
parti le vert dans les joues et le cœur
qui bat vite le cœur qui bat vite
chaleur dans les joues j'ai pas entendu
c'est quoi ce plateau de merde c'est
quoi ce plateau de merde la pensée on
veut ils ont fait exprès ouais ils ont
fait exprès on m'en veut donc si on
déploie un peu ce qui se passe vous êtes
d'accord que il y a un coup de stress
ouais quand on va être dans des
situations stressantes on va beaucoup
plus vite se dire ah mais là je suis en
état de stress je plutôt d'abord
m'occuper de de réguler mon stress avant
de avant de croire à mes interprétations
la pleine conscience ça aide à ça
notamment hein c'est plus vaste que ça
mais notamment on va pas changer ce qui
nous arrive mais on va changer la façon
dont on regarde ce qui nous
arrive parfois la compassion qui est
ressentir la souffrance de l'autre et
avoir suffisamment de stabilité en moi
pour trouver du
courage pour l'aider et l'accompagner je
ne l'ai que si je suis pas dans du
stress intense parce que sinon c'est pas
du courage que je vais avoir c'est de
l'aversion en me disant c'est bon moi
j'ai eu ma dose si j'ai entendu toute la
journée des personnes qui souffrent à
qui j'annonce des diagnostiques
difficiles par exemple et que je ne me
ressource pas à la fin enfin le mot est
fort mais quand même je risque d'être
maltraitante pour les personnes à qui je
m'adresse évidemment je c'est pas mon
intention mais c'est ce qui va sortir
parce que j'en peux
plus
jeis au tout début de la
formation je prends conscience des
choses après les rectifier c'est je
pense un travail de longue haleine ça va
être essentiellement déjà cette
dispersion éviter la dispersion
éviter ce ce happing d'une tâche à
l'autre en disant il faut que j'envoie
alors je me recentre et puis je je me
concentre sur ce que j'ai à faire
maintenant dans l'instant présent et je
me projette pas à ce que j'ai à faire
demain rappeler un tel à faire un mail à
un tel c'est c'est ça en fait qui c'est
cette gymnastique d'esprit c'est ce
vagabondage mental qui est un peu
épuisant tu vois je me suis trompé de
route c'est la concentration tu la
dispersion
mentale bonjour Marie salut tu vas bien
ouais tu as vu je t'avais laissé des
petits mot dou
oui tu es pas très en forme tu es pas
très en forme je
chtigé c'est un week mais parce que du
coup Marie elle travaille aussi le
weekend donc donc quelleure ce matin ce
matin là je crois qu'on va pouvoir le
féliciter ce Monsieur H par c'est 93 il
est 75 oh et après ce monsieur c'est un
monsieur que je connais déjà et j'ai pas
noté j'ai un trou de
mémoire qu'on soit en forme par que moi
je
t'ard comment ça va je m'en sors pas
trop mal par rapport au poids c'est ça
qui par rapport non je suis à 7 non
c'est hyper bien je me suis dit je vais
le faciter il pass hy bien,5 en étant
inactif ça veut dire que ça pourrait
être 6 5 en bougeant ça serait
génial comment on peut faire allez-y je
vous en
prie dans votre vie en général là vous
ça va plutôt dans mon vie en général
c'est juste des gouttes qui me fatig oui
la gout de goutte ça les douleurs au
pied mais donc du coup entre les
douleurs la formation terminée ouais
c'est
ça
génial
waouh top ça c'est mon qui m'a envoyé
c'est
super et ben bravo mé c'est ça et donc
là vous allez donc un localant un local
ouais voilà et bravo he félicitations
c'est super ce que vous avez fait
c'était difficile mais çair c'était
difficile surmonter tout ça c'est très
bien ça me chamboule ouais ça me
chamboule puis finalement de voir aussi
les réaction des collègues enfin tout ce
qui émerge de cette formation sent on
sent les sensibilités les difficultés
les voilà on a tous nos petites
blessures donc en fait on vient tous là
avec nos bagages
et on se révèle un peu et puis on
découvre aussi on se découvre on on se
réécoute en fait aussi nous en tant que
soignant par qu'on faisait peut-être pas
jusqu'à présent en fait trouver le temps
de s'écouter dans nos propres besoins de
soignant pour pouvoir
être à l'écoute des autres c'est donc ça
marche ça marche
ouais allez-yz-vous
entrez entrez venez il y encore de de
côté allez entrez entrez
entrezs
bonjour je suis ravi d'être là c'est
c'est super vous avez l'air à peu près
tous tout en forme euh c'est pas un
cours vous avez compris on va essayer de
de vivre un truc ensemble donc ce que je
vous propose c'est tout de suite une
première pratique et ensuite qui va
permettre ensuite de faire le petit tour
je vais vous poser trois
questions comment ça va pour moi auj
aujourd'hui on va passer à si vous
voulez bien à la deuxième
question comment ça va pour moi
maintenant la
dernière comment ça va pour moi à cet
instant
voilà laisser émerger de manière assez
spontanée qu'est-ce que vous avez envie
de partager bonjour moi c'est
Alexandra la question du ça va
effectivement ça m'a rejoint sur le
d'hier la question d'IER donc je me suis
fait un petit bisc ça allait bien la
deuxième question bon elle a commencé à
être je me suis dit B c'est bon j'ai
fait mon bon scan j'ai pas de douleur je
dis je vais être bien ok
qui question et par contre la troisième
m'a vraiment agacé et corporellement
c'est là où bah du coup j'ai dû bah
ouvrir les yeux parce que je sentais que
bah c'est bon j'avais fait mon bcal je
me sentais bien on insistais et en fait
j'étais ok donc ok je voulais pas ça
donc j'ai ouvert les yeux plutôt et je
pense que avec un press ce ce recul
c'est que je j'ai pas de théorie et là
j'ai j'ai l'impression alors c'est pas
contre vous mais j'ai l'impression de
repartir sur un cours où j'ai
l'impression que je vais encore avoir un
manque et du coup je je je suis sur
cette fin là me dire mais ça va être
quoi la la suite parce que là encore une
fois on est en train de faire un tour
excusez-moi mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est une perte de temps parce que je
suis venu pour un du pour apprendre
quelque chose et j'écoute les histoires
des autres ok qui sont intéressantes et
je suis je suis tout cœur avec tout le
monde mais je pourend quelque chose
voilà et et je suis dans cette attente
merci merci beaucoup ce que vous avez
amené là c'est c'est le cœur de ce qui
nous empêche d'être compassionnel et on
est tous comme ça c'est pas vous que je
vise en particulier mais merci de
l'avoir articulé comme disent les
Américains donc ce moment là il est
vraiment fondamental c'est le moment le
plus important là du cours c'est ce
qu'on est en train de vivre pas ce qu'on
est en train d'apprendre parce que ce
qu'on est en train d'apprendre c'est ce
qu'on croit apprendre ce qu'on est en
train de vivre c'est ce qu'on apprend
vraiment ce qu'on intègre donc il y a la
connaissance je vous assure il y a 10
milliards de bouquins sur la compassion
vous avez eu déjà des cours
magnifiques mais la compassion c'est pas
une théorie c'est la chose la plus
difficile à exercer c'est pour ça qu'on
commence par soi donc merci pour le
ah la violence c'est nous sommes les
premiers responsables de la violence et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi envers
nous-mêmes vous savez que nous sommes
contagieux et c'est pas depuis le covid
nous sommes contagieux ça veut dire que
c'est par l'empathie que nous sommes
contagieux ça veut dire que si je suis
pas Thierry Cardoso mais que je suis
fight ce matin don qu'est-ce qui se
passe la personne elle vient pas voir un
médecin elle vient voir fight Bruce le
énervé ok sauf c'est contagieux ça donc
elle qu'est-ce qui se passe elle a une
souffrance à déposer
elle a nulle part où la déposer
ou plus exactement elle a un endroit où
l' déposé un ring de
boxe dans quel état voulez-vous que la
personne soit est-ce que je peux soigner
cette personneel donc c'est
s'autoriser à voir le champ des
possibles et voir qu'est-ce qui nous
convient le mieux par rapport à ses
propres valeurs par rapport à son chemin
par rapport à ce truc pour être toujours
dans ce discernement de est-ce que je
suis pris par la réactivité et je fais
exprès de dire je suis pris quelqu'un
fait de laikido
ici est-ce que vous accepteriez qu'on
montre quelque chose vous inquiétez pas
on va pas rouler par
[Rires]
terrezo voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe en
général quand on fait
ça on est comme ça et donc là moi
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous remarquez
quelqu'un s'y connait en
surface ça fait combien centimètr la
surface de
prise quelques centimètres ou ça
quelques centimètres donc quand quelques
centimètres sont pris moi je suis
paralysé qu' en réalité là c'est une
prise c'est une information là je suis
détente parce que je vois où est et puis
effectivement je suis complètement libre
tout le reste est et c'est ça qu'on
oublie merci beaucoup vous voyez ce que
je veux dire donc parfois on est saisi
par un tout petit
événement et tout le reste et ça prend
tout merci bonne routeci
mer je pense qu'il y a une chose très
importante aujourd'hui qui est
l'évolution des attentes du public qui
recourt au soins c'est-à-dire tout le
monde et l'évolution de la
représentation du métier de soignant et
moi l'impression que j'ai c'est que il y
a un décalage en fait entre les
soignants dont on a besoin aujourd'hui
et la manière dont on les forme et cette
façon qu'on a eu de vouloir faire des
têtes bien faites c'était tout à fait
légitimé par une évolution scientifique
assez extraordinaire des des quelques
décennies qui viennent de s'écouler mais
c'est aussi ça qui a éloigné les
soignants de leur
posture plus humaine et et du coup il y
a quand même une demande aujourd'hui
enfin on lit ça partout que les
professionnels de santé n'ont plus leur
rôle enfin l'humanité semble sêtre perdu
la relation de soin on sait plus où elle
est et c'est les patients qui s'en
plaignent
est-ce que tu as l'impression que tu es
en train de changer que ce duu est en
train de changer quelque chose en toi ou
dans ta vie dans ta pratique je sens une
évolution bah dans le sens où
j'ai j'ai envie de travailler avec ce
que ressentent vraiment les gens
euh leurs émotions leurs
sentiment apporter en
fait vraiment une dimension plus plus
globale plus humaine à la relation de
soin que j'ai c'est de soigner avec sa
tête mais avec son cœur aussi souvent
ils me disent c'est allé très vite c'est
allé trop vite je n'ai pas eu le temps
de poser des questions j'ai l'impression
de pas avoir été
écouté j'ai l'impression de pas avoir
été compris justement ce ce déb me fait
prendre conscience de ça qu'il faut que
je change les choses que je change des
petites choses mais qu'est-ce qui
t'empêche de le
faire ben je me rends compte que en
participant à ce duu euh
rien en fait j'ai de l'espoir parce que
il est pas trop tard mon épuisement a
commencé mais il est pas terminé donc
c'est le moment ou jamais de changer je
pense et ça fait du
bien BR sera bon ben te vraiment
à voilà
ye on enule dans la salle et au gang il
y aura une première question qui vous
sera posée et vous y répondrez à tour de
rôle au sein de votre
bureau comment ça
va bien question comment vas-tu comment
tu te sens une personne seule encore la
question est depuis le début du duu
qu'est-ce que j'ai particulièrement
apprécié
[Musique]
que
j'avais c'est trop
co on n pas
finias pas fini tu es pas prête elle pas
eu le tempsas trop parlé mais
oui
par moi j'ai déjà pas compris la
démarche appréciative donc j'attends de
des outils chattend là là je suis
demandeuse d'outils et de méthodologie
pour euh avoir une compréhension de la
démarche
appréciative la démarche appréciative
c'est décider de regarder ce qui ce qui
a ce qui est en vitalité ce qui
fonctionne bien ça c'est vraiment un
élément important c'est une manière de
rentrer en relation avec les autres pour
pouvoir rentrer aussi dans des processus
d'intelligence collective et ce qu'on on
leur propose aujourd'hui c'est de euh de
se relier a des expériences importantes
pour eux dans lesquelles ils ont été
dans la qualité de
soins nous vous proposons d'explorer des
situations illustrant une relation
optimale tu vois tu dois avoir en tête
une relation optimale que tu as mis en
place avec un patient hm hm ayant permis
d'accéder au meilleurs résultats
possible pour vous pour le patient pour
ses proches des situations dont vous
pouvez être fier sans fausse
modestie
on n pas tentéi j'étais partie sur un
lien indéflectible oui un accompagnement
sans condition voilà lien
conditionnel qu' un lien qui s
donc six histoires d'abord c'est le
fluide le fluide doré la peluche le
trésor trésors cachés voyageons ensemble
le lotus envasé et chocotrance vous
souhaitez entendre quelle
histoire ch chocotrance alors qui a
récolté
chocotrance Philippe accueiller
quelqu'un qui connaissait et qui était
incapable de se rendre chez le dentiste
pour des soins dentaires qui avait
vraiment une folie de ces soins
là il lui a notamment proposé d'essayer
de retrouver un lieu sécure qu' qu'elle
avait connu ou qu'elle pouvait imaginer
elle a vite trouver ça en repensant à
moment de son enfance notamment des
moments qu'elle passait chez sa
grand-mère
et le titre est notamment en lien avec
ça puisque sa grand-mère lui proposait
un chocolat au lait qu'elle a été
capable de de très bien décrire presque
de ressentir le goût de réavoir l'odeur
en étant en échange avec Philippe sur ce
moment donc c'était quelque chose de
très fort pour elle et pour Philippe
aussi et puis il l'a recroisé quelques
mois plus tard et elle a pu lui dire que
depuis elle avait pu retourner chez le
dentiste et faire ses soins sans
difficulté moi je recrute he je recrute
à
l'hôpital je m'installé à sais pour côté
une mission du directeur recruté quoi je
me suis aperçu là en cours de de de ces
journées de duu que j'avais un fortbiet
négatif en fait et en me disant
effectivement on est toujours quand même
orienté dans les souvenirs sur ce qui
est difficile sur ce qui est négatif et
que finalement on n'apprécie pas assez
au fur et à mesure de nos vies
professionnell ou privé personnel de
toutes les les belles choses qui nous
arrivent voilà chaque journée et et le
fait de se souvenir d'un d'un chouette
truc d'une journéef c'est ça pass ça
permet de bien dormir
quoi je rend compre de l'effet groupe
moi je viens de découvrir ça je n'avais
jamais découvert de choses en groupe à
ce pointl et je suis hyper heureuse
d'être là parmi tout enfin j'ai
rencontré plein de belles personne je
suis vraiment très heureuse et très
remplie de cette nourriture humaine
enfin c'est c'est une expérience
fantastique enfin ça me ça me touche
après une période covid j'ai trouvé des
des super personnes
quoi j'ai l'impression d'avoir vu la
situation que j'avais vécu sous une
forme je sais pas si c'était amélioré ou
synthétiser ou mais je l'ai vu mieux je
l'ai vu plus clair comme si j'avais pris
du recul sur la situation et et puis je
me suis sentie bah valorisé et je pense
qu'il y a quand même une intention
l'intention de se de valoriser les
autres aussi dans cette démarche donc
merci parce que c'était vraiment
chouette
h ce sujet
de bah déjà des médecines
complémentaires ça commence à émerger
quand même au sein de la fac et de la
formation des des médecins et dans notre
formation bon sur la méditation on en
parle encore pas beaucoup mais sur le
côté relation aux patients et ouais
relation médecin patient on nous en
parle de plus en plus et on a un peu on
a eu moi j'ai eu un ou deux ateliers
pendant mon externa sur des simulations
de prise en charge du patient vraiment
dans le relationnel on va le noter sur
votre dossier médical des
dysfonctionnements de du système en
général malheureusement à l'hôpital on
en voit beaucoup par exemple aux
urgences mais c'est plus que moi par
exemple on mettait la pression de faire
un max de consulte parce que j'étais de
garde euh j'ai vu plein de gens qui
étaient qui étaient là parce que ils
étaient juste hyper angoissés c'était
surtout des symptômes de stress
d'angoisse pour moi c'est hyper légitime
quand tu es aux urgences de venir pour
ça en pleine nuit tu vois et et il y a
bah tu as plein de chefs qui vont dire
non mais ça c'est de la merde c'est bon
tu la renvoies chez elle tu la renvoies
chez son médecin traitant bah oui mais
en fait là ça demande c'est que il est
pas bien il est super mal il est stressé
et qu'il a besoin juste qu'on prenne le
temps si tu me permets juste de prendre
15 minutes avec ce patient ça va
peut-être mieux se passer que si on le
renvoie chez lui et qui revient demain
aux urgences la nuit quoi tu as fait le
la copie de ou oui oui de la et elle m'
demandé je fais n'importe quoi là
norteo demandé
Abde ça consiste en quoi ta formation en
fait c'est par on a pas beaucoup parlé
ouais bah en fait c'est un donc c'est un
duu qui consiste en ça s'appelle
méditation et gestion de la relation de
soin en en fait c'est surtout axé sur le
la relation de soin donc le l'empathie
la compassion le rapport mais enfin
c'est très global je sa je saurais pas
comment le résumer en une phrase parce
que il y a tel en fait on a plein de
d'interventions différentes souvent
c'est très interactif il y a aussi pas
mal d'expérienciell et tu as
l'impression que ça t'aide surtout toi
ou ça ça aide tes patients qui sont
mieux devant toi ou les deux ah les deux
la porte d'entrée c'est vraiment la
méditation Mo j'en ai jamais fait je
sais pas ce que c'est j'y connais rien
oui j'espère avoir une bonne relation
avec les gens quand même bah oui mais
non mais en fait tu as raison c'est pas
parce que tu m'édites pas que tu es pas
complètement j'espère oui en tout cas ça
me c'est un sujet qui me plaît quoi
après
quoi moi je trouve ça extrêmement
positif qu'il y a des jeunes médecins
qui se posent ces questions au moment où
ils vont débuter leur carrière j'ai des
souvenirs de situation extrêmement
violentes à la fois pour les patients et
et pour moi et pour mes collègues
internes à l'hôpital oui il y a des il y
a des souvenirs un peu cuisant ouis de
devoir annoncer dans dans l'urgence un
peu entre deux portes des diagnostics ou
des mauvaises nouvelles sans y être du
tout préparé sans être surtout soutenu
par l'équipe soignante enfin on était
souvent quand même largement laissé
laissé à nous-même quoi c'était c'est
pas c'est pas que des bons souvenirs les
les années d'internat à l'hôpital c'est
peut-être pour ça que j'ai tout de suite
voulu m'installer en ville et pas rester
à l'hôpital d'ailleurs moi ça fait
bientôt ça fait plus de 15 ans que je
reçois des internes et à chaque fois
c'est une surprise une relation un
échange un enrichissement dans les deux
sens c'est pas du tout à sens unique
sans mes interne je pense que vraiment
je risqueraiis la déprime et le burnout
quoi et grâce à mes internes
l'enthousiasme est
intact
ouais on bouge les t on bouge les tables
on les met comme
ça Plô par làe
ça en face de
moi on va aborder là ce matin
le le sujet de la prévention et de la
gestion de l'agressivité de la violence
est-ce que vous pouvez me je sais pas me
parler un pe peu de vos quotidien
là-dessus je me souviens d'une patiente
j'ai pas très longtemps qui arrive et
qui me dit j'ai mal à l'épaule mon ostéo
m'a dit qu'il me fallait une RM de
l'épaule donc je viens juste pour que
vous me la prescriv B moi en fait je
l'ai j'ai trouvé ça assez agressif ass
presque un peu intrusif de Me bah de Me
m'imposer son l'examen complémentaire
que je vais lui prescrire quoi une
injonction une injonction exactement
qu'est-ce que ça a produit chez vous
ça ça
m'a je dirais que ça m'a au début ça ça
m'a un peu bah ça m'a surtout interpellé
je me suis je me suis dit bon te te
dégonfle pas bah tiens-toi bien comme
elle bien droit aussi parce qu'il y
avait il y avait quelque chose vraiment
de physique elle se tenait très presque
elle est resté debout
enfin et puis après je enfin ça m'a
agacé puis je me suis dit là ça va me
mener à rien si je reste dans cette
posture là le but est d'essayer de
d'avoir un échange quand vous dites je
suis un petit peu agacée c'est
complètement normal c'est légitime hein
mais ça va ça ne va pas être neutre dans
la façon d'intervenir dans ce qui va se
passer ensuite alors je vais vous faire
de deux petites des petites scettes de
de situation hein alors je viens vous
voir pour une RM là voilà mon ostéopathe
m'a dit que fallit une RM donc voilà
j'en ai pas pour longtemps je suis un
peu pressée si vous pouviez me faire
l'ordonnance s'il vous
plaît faut je
répond ça vous pose un
problème ben on va on va en discuter non
bah non non euh assdez-vous déjà non non
j'ai j'ai besoin de ça j'ai juste besoin
d'une ordonnance si vous voulez discuter
on reprendra un rendez-vous après là
j'ai besoin de ça juste ben ce que je
vous propose c'est que vous installiez
vous essayez j'ai pas besoin de
m'installer c'est bon j'ai besoin juste
d'ordonnance là
ok vous avez besoin de l'avoir rapid
tout de suite là maintenant il y a
quelque chose qui vous presse qui vous
inquiète mais il y a pas à discuter
là-dessus c'est mon ostéopathe on a déjà
fait le tour de la situation bon
[Musique]
voilà s
anxieuse bon alors
ah c'est agressif c'est quoi c'est
agressif ah moi jouer
l'agressivité ce que
c'est pour calmer quelqu'un qui est dans
un stress de de de fuite donc
d'inquiétude
la seule chose qui fait que vous allez
pouvoir l'aider à en sortir c'est lui
poser une question
ouverte
et d'éviter de lui coller un coup de
contrainte en plus si vous lui dites
mais attendez madame machin MC il a rien
dit avz pris encore pour qu' jours là
c'est
fin c'est foutu là vous la récupérez pas
parce que vous lui mettez un coup de
contrainte tant que je ne suis pas
moi-même calme de de quoi qu'il s'agisse
en face de moi de la réaction de
l'autre que émotionnel ou plutôt de
l'ordre de la dominance et de la
pression je pourrais pas agir
convenablement en tous les cas c'est un
petit peu la la seule manière à mon sens
de s'en sortir à l'intérieur de
d'environnements qui sont difficiles
c'est-à-dire que je peux pas lutter moi
et réformer l'hôpital j'ai pas les
moyens mais par contre ce que je peux
c'est me réformer moi pour avoir plus de
confort avec ce que je vis hein parce
que il y a pas de solution soit je m'en
vais je vais bosser ailleurs soit je
reste je
[Musique]
restetenant va
Esser au début quand je suis arrivé au
duu je pensais que j'allais prendre
quelque chose pour mettre en pratique
sur pour les patients et Corine m'a dit
bah non ce duu il est pour toi c'est un
duu qu'on fait personnellement pour soi
et en fait je le comprenais pas au début
j'arrivais pas à
mettre à me dire ok je le fais pour moi
mais moi la méditation j'en ai jamais
fait c'était vraiment une découverte et
aujourd'hui je peux dire que ce
cheminement là B maintenant tout se
connecte et les les échanges qu'on avait
au début qui me gavaient un petit peu
d'écouter tout le monde quasiment on est
plus d'une trentaine mais maintenant je
trouve ça vraiment très
enrichissant maison santé bonjour
oui d'accord c'est CEP donc le 5 mai en
VSL parfait mais ça sera après demain
madame au revoir bonne journée maison de
santé
bonjour
bon mais ça va être ce soir à 18h45 ou
19h même avec le docteur
casouor allez très
bien oui bonne journée au
revoir maison de
santé coussin de
méditation je le mets sur la chaise là
parce que ça me permet d'être bien assis
d'avoir le dos plus droit parce que si
je mite sans cou en fait sur une chaise
je suis pas bien assis je te montre ça
prend 2
minutes en fait tu as la ligne de ton
bassin qui est un peu auudessus de la
ligne de tes genoux alors que si tu
l'avais
pas et du coup ça te permet de redresser
les
lombaires d beaucoup mieux assis
et du coup voilà je j'utilise cette
position pour
méditer même si c'est normal pour nous
VO vous aimeriez avoir un petit retour
tout est ok voilà c'est vrai que nous on
appelle justeand quand il y a un
problème très bien et ben nickel voilà
parfait très bien merci merci
beaucoup monsieur mis eu dans la mesure
du possible augmenter le temps de
consultation avec les patients
l'après-midi passer de de de 15 à 20
minutes
euh les créneau de consultation et euh 5
minutes ça change beaucoup de choses une
patiente qui est venue me voir ce matin
on avait passé 15 20 minutes à voilà
refire le plan sur son traitement à
l'examiner j'avais passé la carte Vitale
elle m'avait réglé et là
juste avant de partir était encore assis
elle me dit alors il faut que je vous
parle de mon mari un docteur vous savez
il est violent et il arrive
régulièrement qu'il me
batte et c'est une dame que je suis
depuisuis 3 4 ans et elle m'en avait
jamais parlé elle a dû se sentir plus en
confiance un niveau de confiance qui lui
de de s'épencher de
de d'aborder le sujet avec moi
aujourd'hui on a fini la consultation
elle m'a
dit voilà moi je je vous en ai parlé je
me suis senti écoué ça m'a fait du bien
je dirais les gens ont besoin d'amour
ils ont besoin de beaucoup d'amour je
suis désolé je
m'enflamme
ça va l'équipe
là a pas pris de café tiens
[Musique]
ça va
bien oui
je
suis je sais ce que je fais dans ma
pratique je sais ce que j'attends je
sais ce que
j'aimerais maintenant c'est subjectif
c'est propre à chacun donc en fait je
pense que ça va bien se
passer
je forcément stressé en fait c'est la
pression de interne en fait de moi-même
en fait c'est bienveillant pas besoin
que ça se
passe et en fait c'est fort c'est un
schéma qui est profondément
[Musique]
cré je m'appelle Florent cou et je vous
je vous présente mon mémoire pour
l'obtention du diplôme méditation
gestion du stress et relation de soin
comme prof de santé ici on est venu tous
avec notre petite valise du savoir des
connaissances des connaissances
techniques du
savoir-faire voilà mais finalement on se
rend compte au travers de notre
expérience personnelle professionnelle
qu'on est parfois peu outillé sur le
savoir-être la rencontre avec l'hôpital
a pas a pas été si simple et avec la
faculté aussi puisque j'ai été confronté
bah aux
difficultés qu'on connaît de de de
l'hôpital en France en ce moment puis il
y a eu aussi la compétition dans les
études de médecine où au début c'était
très festif et tout ça puis rapidement
je trouve qu' a grandi un peu une une
atmosphère de compétition de concurrence
et moi j'étais pas trop venue chercher
ça enfin je pensais qu'en faisant
médecine j'aurais juste un environnement
très bienveillant j'ai toujours été un
médecin en fait sensible à la souffrance
des gens que je soignais mais quand
j'étais jeune ça ça glissait un peu sur
moi et puis en venant sur les ban de la
fac je m'étais dit voilà alors on va
nous apprendre comment on prend soin des
autres un peu mieux trouver des
solutions parce que faut sans forcément
trouver des solutions quand on fait une
consultation faut trouver la solution
puis finalement en fin d'année ben j'ai
un peu comment dire compléter mon schéma
en disant que finalement méditer c'est
pas être que dans son esprit mais c'est
aussi être dans son corps et que le
corps faisait faisait partie intégrante
de nous-même le fait de pouvoir partager
parfois un petit peu de notre humanité
avec le patient et c'était pas
complètement interdit contrairement à ce
que j'avais pu retenir de ce que j'avais
retenu à la fac de ce que j'avais
compris à la fac donc j'ai compris que
j'avais besoin de de créer enfin d'avoir
vraiment pour moi un espace de de
soin de douceur de d'apaisement et puis
ça a été l'occasion de réaliser que
prendre soin de moi n'était pas une
option sans influence de de ce du je
vois pas comment je pourrais continuer à
travailler
sans sans apporter cette nouvelle touche
euh à mon travail et euh si j'avais un
pldoyer ce serait de peut-être placer
cette formation qui est une formation
universitaire complémentaire un choix
mais en tant que formation initiale au
sein des études médicales je pense que
ça rendrait service à beaucoup de futurs
[Musique]
soignants quand nous on a eu
l'autorisation d'ouvrir le duu bah
d'autres facultés d'autres universités
ont démarré dans les facs de médecine il
y en a une dizaine qui ont monté des
diplômes universit sur ces questions là
après est-ce qu'il faut que 100 % des
soignants soient formés à ces approches
peut-être
[Musique]
pas moi je suis pas pour une obligation
ou une intégration obligatoire mais
parce que je crois pas qu'on puisse
obliger les gens à pratiquer la
méditation ça ça me paraît totalement
exclu par contre en avoir entendu parler
suffisamment pour pouvoir euh pour que
les patients sachent qu'ils peuvent
échanger avec leur professionnel de
santé sur des questions qui sont pas la
santé
allopathique classique ça c'est très
important si on veut prendre en charge
les patients de manière globale on peut
pas ne pas s'intéresser à la moitié des
pratiques auxquelles il recourt pour
aller mieux c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
vous
n'impor